packing the supreme court isn't
unconstitutional
congress does have that power
but packing it with this intention in
mind under this circumstance
really is
anti-constitutional it would undermine
the separation of power
not not as a bug but as a feature and
that's what makes it so wrong
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
the senior senator from the great state
of utah and the author of the new book
saving nine the fight against the left's
audacious plan to pack the supreme court
and destroy american liberty senator
mike lee finally welcome to the reuben
report
thank you very much it's good to be with
you
well you have handed me an awful lot
that i'm talking an awful lot about in
the title of the new book and i want to
focus an awful lot on that but first
what is it like to be on the short list
of what i would call
uh sane people in the united states
government right now yeah it's sort of
like
being one of the tallest buildings in
tooele utah you might say there are a
lot of tall buildings here i take it
short buildings over there yeah i mean
what is going on
yeah so what is going on right now with
the government and just the amount of
people that seemingly are doing nothing
or all of the wrong things yeah
the the problem is less about doing
nothing and more about doing all the
wrong things
when people start to think that god is
government and when they start to think
that all government needs to take place
and transpire in washington dc that's a
wicked combination a combination we've
been living under for many decades but
it's reached a boiling point of late and
the left wants to make it a lot worse
we're here to stop it
so that really is in many ways what the
book is about and one of the things that
you talk about and i've been trying to
hit on for a while on the show i i have
tried and i generally try not to impugn
people's motives but as you know the
road to hell is paved with good
intentions and it seems to me at this
point what we are seeing out of the left
and virtually the entire democrat party
is an intentional destruction of so many
of the things that the founders uh had
built and and had created to allow us to
all live free so before we get into the
specifics what do you think about the
intentions part do you think a lot of
what's going on is intentional or do you
think it's confusion or a
misunderstanding of the documents or
something else altogether
you know i tend to believe that most
people on the left
have at least convinced themselves that
the place they want to take us is a good
place that that would be good for the
country in the case of packing the
supreme court for example i i think they
somehow believe that that would take us
to a better place now i i wrote saving
nine in order to explain why the
opposite is true
so but regardless of what their
intention is i have no ability to jump
into someone else's mind to read their
mind to know the the inner
thoughts and intentions of their heart
and their soul and their mind but what i
do know is uh
certain things that history tells us and
history tells us that there are some
mistakes we ought not want to repeat as
mitch mcconnell likes to say there's no
education in the second kick from the
mule we've already been kicked by the
court packing mule once i describe that
at great length in chapter four of
saving nine we do not want the education
that would come from the second kick of
that same mule
so when you hear your colleagues across
the aisle talking about packing the
court and you're hearing it all the time
now i mean it's virtually every day
someone is saying it um do you ever try
to pull them aside and say hey do you
guys realize that if you pack the court
this time we'll just pack the court next
time or that perhaps this is a complete
affront to the separation of powers or a
series of other things that you get into
in the book but you kind of say them hey
do you realize what you're going to do
here even if you temporarily get what
you want of course of course and you
know for the time being
they're they're content with talking
about it but not really doing it at
least not yet i think they're waiting to
do that perhaps until the dobbs ruling
is actually issued and maybe that's when
they start through it in earnest then it
gets very very serious but i think
you're right to point that out i don't
think they really want to go where
they're trying to take us either if they
really think about it you know i hope
they will read saving nine
because regardless of whether they agree
with me on any other policy issue they
ought to be able to agree that the
minute you rip off that band-aid and for
reasons i explain in the book the minute
you
start to politicize the court formally
as you would do by increasing the number
of justices in order to achieve a
desired political outcome
there is no stopping it
the republicans who in modern history
have never attempted anything like this
would be compelled
to do the same thing the next time the
shoe is on the other foot that is the
next time the house and the senate and
the white house are all under the
control of the same party if the
democrats increase by four you can see
republicans increasing up by four more
maybe it will be six next time
the result of that won't be pleasant for
anyone the court because of the lifetime
appointment guarantee of article three
of the constitution
this will be a one-way ratchet
and the court will expand a lot faster
than it could ever shrink before long it
won't look like a court at all but like
a political body and a large one at that
uh eventually it looked like the
intergalactic senate in the star wars
movie series
uh believe it or not i am a big fan of
the prequels and i think that they're
looking better and better over time
because of exactly that but you know how
power just flips depending on who's in
charge um at what point do you think
that packing the court is actually an
assault on the constitution itself in in
other words that one branch of
government would in essence be
destroying another branch of government
they're supposed to have checks and
balances but to me that's a it's almost
a violation of the oath of office if you
if your goal as a legislator
is to override what the judiciary is
supposed to be comprised of yeah no
that's exactly right and i think if
you're doing it the minute you're doing
it not because the court is short
staffed i i think in theory that could
be a legitimate reason to do it if it's
some unknown point in the future uh
there's widespread consensus that there
uh the the human resources on the court
uh have been outpaced by the caseload
you could consider an argument then even
then you would want to be very careful
about phasing in the increases uh but
whereas here they're just talking about
a political outcome that they desire
they want to achieve then this is an
assault on that thing here's the
interesting thing about that um
it's kind of an irony built into it
packing the supreme court isn't
unconstitutional
it congress does have that power
but packing it with this intention in
mind under this circumstance
really is
anti-constitutional it would undermine
the separation of powers
not not as a bug but as a feature and
that's what makes it so wrong
but do you think it matters to them you
know what i mean like they sort of their
their ends justify the means so do you
think it really matters meaning that if
they can go ahead and do it and get away
with it which seemingly you can get away
with virtually anything these days then
why not go ahead and do it i know that's
not your position but from their
perspective from their perspective that
often is a big motivator and i think
that is part of why they're doing it
notwithstanding some of these risks
is that they're looking at this saying
if we can do it and it would please our
base
why not do it
uh why not at least try maybe we will
swing and miss but we'll at least draw a
lot of great applause
from our own base
but for the reasons i explain in chapter
four of saving nine
even when you
swing and miss even when you threaten to
pack the court you propose court packing
and the legislation fails it can leave
an indelible mark a mark that we're
still paying for uh in the
you know
lengthy
period of time it's elapsed since 1937
when they tried it last we're still
suffering from what happened to the
court what it did to the court
all
that many years ago 85 years later and
we're still paying for that mistake
so you write about that pretty
extensively actually so can you just go
into what happened those 85 years ago
yeah 85 years ago
you had a supreme court that was doing
its job and was enforcing the outer
limits on congress's authority
especially its authority under the
commerce clause the part that gives
congress the power to regulate trade or
commerce between the states and the
foreign nations
and
fdr president franklin d roosevelt was
frustrated at the fact that the supreme
court was knocking down some of his
signature pieces of legislation giving
congress and the federal government as a
whole
unprecedented power to deal with things
in response to the great depression they
wanted to be able to regulate
uh things like agriculture and
mining and labor and manufacturing even
though historically those have been
regulated
almost exclusively by the states and not
the federal government
now the supreme court just interpreting
the constitution based on what it had
always meant
was threatened by fdr
just two years
after the court had moved into its new
building
the building it now occupies on april 12
1937 the supreme court effectively
rewrote the constitution it rewrote the
commerce clause to give the federal
government the power to regulate
anything that even affected interstate
commerce not just interstate commercial
transactions or the corridors through
which they take place
but anything that affects those things
could now be regulated by congress that
meant labor manufacturing agriculture
mining all the things that fdr wanted to
be able to regulate comprehensively from
washington d.c they could now do
this occurred as a result of one vote
switching
associate justice owen roberts who had
previously stood by uh others on the
court who would acknowledge there were
limits on on the congress's commerce
clause authority
he switched his vote he joined with the
liberals on the court and they rewrote
the constitution and it's a result of
that
that we're now dealing with the federal
government that regulates every aspect
of human existence that imposes two
trillion dollars of regulatory
compliance costs on the american economy
that requires americans to work for
months out of every year just to pay
their federal taxes and then tells them
that even that's not enough because
we're 31 trillion dollars in debt
all of that and the fact that most of
our laws at the federal level are now
made by unelected unaccountable
bureaucrats that can all be traced to
this switch in time that saved nine
uh as i explained in chapter four of
saving nine
so as a as a free market guy as a
capitalist guy as a guy that believes in
states rights and you want the free
exchange of goods
what should we be doing to uh maybe get
more people we can talk about it and get
more people to know about it and you can
write books about it but what can we do
to to get that case to be looked at
again perhaps well yeah so first of all
we need to get people talking about
federalism and separation of powers
because that's what we lost the last
time the democrats tried to pack the
court
when we get people talking about that we
make it part of the national political
discourse
you shouldn't have anyone running
especially as a republican but really
from either party for the u.s house or
the u.s senate or the presidency of the
united states
without them talking about where they
stand on how to restore federalism
the vertical protection that keeps most
of the power at the state and local
level and how to restore separation of
powers the horizontal protection that
says we're going to have one branch of
government that makes the laws congress
the legislative branch one branch of
government headed by the president
the executive branch that enforces the
laws and another branch that interprets
the laws headed by the supreme court
those need to become mainstream
political conversation topics in america
again especially for federal races
that is really how we fix this but in
the meantime we've got to also
counteract the clear and present threat
that we face due to this now trending
hashtag of hashtag expand the court
pioneered by elizabeth warren and others
who are trying overtly to attack the
independence of the federal judiciary
so i know we could we could bash the
progressives in the left all day long
but it's obviously not just them that
have you know expanded the size of
government and the budgets and all of
those things and sending money to all
sorts of countries when we barely have a
dime here what do you think the
republicans and conservatives could be
doing better in terms of giving some of
the power back to the states and in
terms of reining in some of the budgets
and that kind of stuff yeah nobody it's
a fair point you make i mean look this
expansion of the size scope reach and
cost of the federal government this has
occurred under the direction of
uh houses of representatives of
senates and of white houses of every
conceivable partisan combination
the problem is that we've got the
progressive mindset that permeates the
entirety of the democratic party and
a significant portion of the republican
party and i think we have to focus on
that as republicans and say look we're
not the party of progressives we're the
party of liberty we're the party of free
markets we're the party of civil society
all those things atrophy when we
excessively flex the federal muscle and
that's what we've got to undo and in
that respect saving nine is about much
much more
than just preserving the independence of
the supreme court and prohibiting court
packing it's about restoring federalism
and separation of powers this book will
teach you how to do that
so you mentioned politics entering the
court uh obviously at this point because
politics has become our national
religion it seems almost impossible not
to i had judge napolitano from fox on a
couple weeks ago in the middle of the
katanji brown jackson hearing and his
position was that basically
the senate should confirm a judge that
is you know nominated by the president
barring something really off the charts
like really really beyond unbelievable
in a decision that they made that
basically the decision should be left to
the president and short of something
really catastrophic the person should be
confirmed now we watch confirmation
hearings and on both sides it's it's all
sorts of you know dredging out all kinds
of horrible things or made up things in
the case of brett kavanaugh um perhaps
in katanji brown's case the fact that
she couldn't tell you what a woman was
maybe that was a catastrophic uh thing
that would have qualified but what's
your general position on when a
president nominates someone what the
process should actually look like look i
i make uh
no mystery about the fact that um
when there is a democratic president in
office i understand that we're not going
to get the same nominees
as we would
when there's a republican
holding the office of the presidency
still
it still matters and it still matters to
me to review each candidate individually
and figure out whether he or she
uh understands respects appreciates and
will defiantly protect the independence
of the judiciary and will
understand uh that
each case is to be decided on the basis
of its own merits and on the basis of
what the law says
on the basis of the law as it was
understood at the time of an it's an
accident if a statute or at the time of
its ratification if it's a provision of
the constitution and so i'll vote yes
for a nominee even if that nominee
doesn't share my political worldview if
i think that nominee uh is sufficiently
committed to the judicial task if not i
won't so i i don't know that that ought
to ever mean
um blind deference to any president
whether that president is of your own
political party or not uh it certainly
doesn't mean that to me and i don't
think it should to anyone else either
you mentioned the dobbs case before you
know it's kind of bizarre you know this
this leak happens you know now it's
probably six weeks ago or so
and
basically not only are we not talking
about it anymore but it doesn't seem
like anyone's trying to track down the
leaker um are you aware of anything
that's going on that maybe we're not
fully aware of through the media yet and
and what do you think that the leak
itself
uh has done to the integrity of the
court
you know until fairly recently i i i was
convinced that they had identified the
leaker and they just had made a
strategic decision within the court not
to announce the leaker's identity until
after the dobbs case was decided which
may not happen until the end of the
court's term which usually wraps up in
the final days of the month of june
but then a few days ago
news reports started to surface
suggesting that the investigation is
still ongoing that they've asked law
clerks
there are four for each justice
to submit their phone records and submit
sworn affidavits
about their
conduct of this in this case about
what if anything they have done with
copies of supreme court opinions so it
seems to be that the investigation is
ongoing i do think they'll figure it out
who it is because we're dealing with a
fairly finite group of people
and it's uh it's not that hard to figure
out i think we'll find out whoever it is
if if as i suspect it is a law court
they should never practice law again
they should be disbarred for this
because this is handling sensitive
information information that was not
theirs to release and you know as a law
clerk they drill this into you it was
made clear to me when i was a law clerk
at the supreme court for justice alito
you you don't take draft opinions
out of the building ever you don't take
it to lunch you don't take it home it
shouldn't even leave your office when
you're finished with it you can't just
throw it in the waste basket you've got
to put it in this special bag a bag
whose contents are retrieved at the end
of every day
they retrieve the contents they
shred the documents not just once but
twice turning it into a confetti
and then they put it in an incinerator
and put it into this black powder and
then they add a little bit of water to
it and it creates this tar-like slurry
structure before it ever leaves the
custody of the supreme court of the
united states that's how seriously they
take the confidentiality of the opinion
drafting process so whoever did this
knows darn well what those procedures
are and why they matter that's why that
person should never be permitted to
practice law again i do think they'll
figure it out
so assuming they do figure it out or
even if they don't what do you think
it's done just generally to the to the
integrity of the court the ability for
the court
to make a decision hold a decision until
the time is right for it to be released
and just the way the media reacts to all
of it because obviously this was leaked
to politico
they had their decision on whether to
release it or not or verify it in other
ways from everything we understand it is
legit but just the general standing of
the court which to me the left is
constantly trying to subvert anyway not
just through packing but generally just
assault all of the decisions
yeah i think it's devastating i think
it's devastating look the court has
enjoyed a a a history in which this has
not occurred now that the
left-wing media is fond of saying things
like oh this isn't the first time this
has happened other leaks have happened
yeah sure every once in a while maybe
once or twice in a decade word will leak
out maybe an hour or two before an
opinion is released
suggesting that the person knows what
the answer is going to be and most of
the time it's a 50 50 guess anyway it's
like betting on red or black at the
roulette wheel you're gonna be right on
average half the time and sometimes they
get that right
but they've never leaked an entire draft
opinion this has never happened before
there's been a a
network of trust within the court and
there's been
unanimous support within the court and
its support staff and making sure this
doesn't happen
so i think we can stem the damage moving
forward as long as the court takes
additional security steps to make sure
this never happens again but i think
they're going to have to put
in place some sophisticated watermarks
uh behind every draft opinion from now
on that will identify
that the person who had access to that
watermark so that a leak like this can't
happen and if it does happen the person
will be immediately found
so you mentioned federalism earlier in
states rights obviously
as i mentioned to you right before we
started i spent the last eight years of
my life in california i now live in the
free state of florida and as i've been
saying on the show i i genuinely feel
like i live in a different country not
in a different state but in a different
country i'm wondering what what do you
see differently on the ground in terms
of what your constituents want in utah
and the way that you feel that you can
govern there
versus what goes on when you show up in
dc and what you have to deal with yep
that's a good question look um most
americans i it's true of utahns and i
i'm pretty sure it's true of
californians and people in massachusetts
in wyoming or whatever state you want to
identify most americans intuitively
resonate with the concept of federalism
and by the way i refer to it by that
title rather than as states rights
because i my belief is that a state is a
unit of government
units of government don't have
rights they have authority authority is
almost the opposite of a right
so it's recognizing the appropriate
sphere of government authority that's
what federalism is and most people
understand that federalism makes sense
because it allows for more americans to
gain access to more of the kind of
government they want and less of the
kind of government they don't want so
for instance in utah it's pretty well
understood that we'd rather not have a
government-funded single-payer
health care system we've
have enough experiences going to the
post office or the dmv to know that we
don't want government uh being our
doctor uh people in vermont i'm told
would much prefer a single-payer
government-funded government-run health
care system
if we respected federalism more
completely
then more states would be able to do
exactly as they want vermont would be
able to go in that direction utahns
wouldn't do that that's what federalism
is supposed to be all about that's why
it's protected in the text that the
original constitution doubled down on in
the 10th amendment but we've neglected
it federalism still has great potential
we just have to allow it to be used and
for that to happen people in congress
have got to stop pretending that we are
a general purpose legislative body we're
supposed to be in charge of just a few
basic things national defense declaring
war weights and measures trademarks
copyrights and patents
bankruptcy laws regulating trade or
commerce between the states with foreign
nations and with the indian tribes and
that's about it there are a few others
but there's not much more than that
everything else is supposed to be
reserved for the states and localities
you know it's funny because i asked you
this already but when i hear you say
that and lay it out so cleanly and
clearly and obviously it's just like
what what the bell in my head goes off
of i just don't think any democrat
senators care about that i think a
certain amount of republicans don't but
i honestly don't think that any democrat
i cannot name one i if you if you can
name one i'd love to hear it but i just
don't think they care about what it is
what you guys are supposed to do yeah i
think that's right uh for for two
principal reasons uh i don't um
number one um
if they can win they can win bigly uh as
as they might be inclined to put it
number two they are winning
in that they have federalized everything
and this is the ultimate progressive
dream
is to consolidate as much government
power as possible consolidate it in the
national government that way
states won't even have the opportunity
of experimenting with a lower profile
system of government
even though they themselves might like
certain aspects of federalism in these
leftist states they can't tolerate the
thought
of other states states like mine states
like the state of utah doing it
differently they don't want the
competition and they also think that in
order to redeem us in order to save us
from ourselves we've got to nationalize
all of our law making what does that get
us well it gets us a whole lot of
contention it gets us riots it gets
it causes us to create something akin to
an imperial presidency in which the
people seem to worship government
increasingly thinking that the bigger
the government in question the better
off we all are reinforcing the
progressive mindset
i thought you were going to make a
palpatine reference there i felt it
coming it could have come but yeah i
couldn't quite make it
um so on something like the the 40
billion to ukraine that the senate just
voted on uh obviously your your
counterpart there in utah did vote for
it mitt romney did vote for it you know
from my audience's perspective for the
most part it's like man we have so many
things we could be fixing here if we
even have this money in the first place
which we kind of don't have but we
seemingly always have money for other
people's problems not for our own how do
you kind of deal with that internal
battle of again what you're dealing with
in dc and what kind of the machine wants
versus what your own people want and for
a guy like you you actually care about
budgets and i have a suspicion you know
that the 40 billion doesn't really exist
is that fair to say
yeah so i i looked at that legislation
and went through it with a fine-tooth
comb and what i found were some
significant problems number one uh we're
dealing with rampant inflation in this
country the people in utah are paying an
additional 751 dollars each month every
month for their basic living expenses
relative to what they were paying at the
beginning of just last year
this is a huge de facto tax increase
that disproportionately harms
the poor and middle class of my state
and it's entirely foreseeable it is the
natural consequence of
excessive federal spending and so i
thought that the ukraine bill should
have been paid for should have been
offset and i introduced an amendment to
that effect that would have done that
also in that same amendment was language
that would have stripped out title five
of that bill title five is where the
worst spending abuses within the bill
could be found or we're talking a large
amount of money about 15 billion or so
that would have gone to
activities in the state department
that are at best tangentially related to
ukraine and in many instances have been
linked by this administration itself to
the administration's radical climate
change fighting agenda
[Music]
so
when rand paul for example said hey we
should at least be able to
you know know where the money's going or
audit this thing or get some receipts
and basically the entire media tried to
destroy him as if you know he's in
putin's pocket um i'm guessing you were
pretty sympathetic to what he was going
through absolutely absolutely yeah the
same thing happened to me i mean
the the changes rand paul proposed let's
have an inspector general over this very
reasonable in fact i i i it's hard for
me to imagine
that subset of americans who wouldn't
want something like that in place
likewise with my bill
there's nothing that should be terribly
objectionable about saying
we should offset this spending so that
we reduce the inflationary pressures
that we're exerting on the economy and
as long as we're passing a bill that's
supposed to be about ukraine
it shouldn't be about uh
further entrenching the state department
and just flooding
uh the state department itself with
additional funds
so when you not to i'm not trying to
create a fight with you and your your
counterpart your other senator in utah
but like did you admit discuss that and
did he say i'm just kind of okay with it
or or not even about him but just
generally when you spoke to some other
republican senators that just kind of
signed it and we're just like oh we're
doing it
what do people say yeah that's the
problem that's one of my biggest
frustrations with washington is that
people will uh sign on to what i refer
to as the sort of bumper sticker effect
of a particular bill
and for many of my colleagues um
they they looked at this and said look
ukraine is important ukraine is a
sympathetic victim to a vile menace to
human civilization who is vladimir putin
and vladimir putin is in fact a vile
menace and ukraine is a sympathetic
victim here
uh but
to translate that into saying because i
like x and x would be covered in one way
or another by this bill i must vote for
this bill
causes us to enact some very bad
policies
it causes us to spend way too much money
and it's frankly one of the biggest
reasons why we're 31 trillion dollars in
debt
these people are afraid to be seen as
voting against a sympathetic beneficiary
or a combination thereof and that's how
we get to this problem so it's a the
basic difference of opinion that i have
with some of my colleagues who will look
at something and say i agree with the
overall objectives so i'm willing to
vote for it even though this particular
form formulation has some serious
problems with it
so since you are a guy that cares about
the actual rules and the way that we're
supposed to be governed i mean in effect
it seems like we're at war right now i
mean we haven't declared war i know the
president's supposed to declare war it
has to get authorized and everything
else but i mean when you're pouring tons
of money into something when you're
giving people weapons etc etc you in
essence are at war i mean at what point
do we start looking at that and and
having congress or the senate go boy uh
are we at war and how much money do you
have to pour into something before you
officially call it ward if you keep
giving a guy weapons maybe it is war or
again is that just one of those things
that it's just kind of it is what it is
and the the beat goes on yeah i think
it's it's absolutely essential that
before we take any more steps in the
direction of warfare
that
we take into account our role as a
congress in declaring war
over many decades congress has gradually
relinquished its
declaration of war powers as
presidents of both political parties
have asserted really broad powers
attached to their inherent authority
under article 2 as commander in chief of
the armed forces
this is problematic because it was one
of the distinguishing characteristics
of the constitution one of the things
that made it very different than the
english model the system that we had
just broken away from
allowed the chief executive the king
to take us to war and then it was up to
parliament to figure out how to pay for
it
under our system federalist 69 makes
this very clear when alexander alexander
hamilton explains that it was with good
reason we put the power to declare war
in the first instance in the hands of
congress because that's the branch most
accountable to the people at the most
regular intervals so i think if we're
going to take
any additional steps in this area we
really ought to have a conversation
about whether in what way to what extent
we want to be involved in a conflict
with russia
keep in mind ukraine spends less than
five billion dollars a year in defense
russia spends about 65 billion dollars a
year in defense if you add up the
previous ukraine bill 14 billion to this
ukraine bill uh 40 billion
you're talking about
more than 10 times what ukraine spends
on defense
in an entire year
uh is what
we have devoted in the name of ukraine
defense and we're knocking on the door
of what russia spends on defense
worldwide in an entire year
do you think we're in a a bizarre
situation as the last superpower that
we're still expected to do everything
but maybe we kind of just can't in a
certain respect
i i personally believe that i believe in
american exceptionalism i believe the
world is better when we're leading i
believe in peace through strength all of
those things but that maybe right now
especially with the leadership that we
have that we just can't do that much
good
at the moment
in these big international things well
yeah look i think this is where we get
dangerously off course i think it is
dangerous for any country a
last-standing superpower or not to step
into the mindset that says
if there is injustice in the world we
can be counted on as the presumptive
uh
police force
no nation can do that no nation can
withstand that
certainly we can't our constitutional
system should never allow that to happen
uh what really needs to happen is that
any time we get involved militarily we
really ought to have congress declaring
war before we take any action in that
direction
and
always the inquiry should be on
not on whether bad people are doing bad
things in another part of the world
but on how that affects american
national security the safety security
the liberty of the american people at
home
if we can't connect it to that
we shouldn't be doing it
because there is no end to the threats
that we will face the battles we will
have to fight with no real corresponding
ability uh
to do all of those things if our only
test is to go out there and find bad
people doing bad things we'll be very
busy so busy indeed that we will leave
the american people vulnerable in their
own homeland
so speaking of safety and liberty at
home uh you know two years or two and a
half years post covid um are you
are you hopeful that more people have
woken up to some of the state's right
stuff some of the stuff related to the
courts
and mandates and all of the overreach
that we saw i mean my sense is that a
lot of people really have woken up i
don't know if they got scared again if
they would just drop all of their
newfound ideas very quickly in the name
of security but i'm kind of hopeful at
the moment yeah
as my wife sharon would put it
all all government overreach all
socialism and all other forms of
government overreach it always starts
out
under the auspices of an emergency and i
think that's
the awful truth to which the american
people have awakened over the last two
years they've realized oh my gosh if
they can call something an emergency
they can do anything they want and when
government can do anything it wants and
the people feel fear the government
rather than
the other way around
horrible things happen so yeah i think
that has created a number of accidental
conservatives and libertarians in this
country as they've seen that horrible
abuses of government as it goes
unquestioned uh all under the auspices
of uh well this is necessary because of
an emergency
what do we do about organizations like
the cdc and the fda i mean they're
they're not legislative bodies but in
essence it seems like they legislate and
then they it seems like well you just
turn on any corporate news and they're
all sponsored by pfizer sponsored by
moderna as they're
doing stories on pfizer on moderna what
do we do about that mess yeah
it's a it's a great point by the way i i
talk about this a fair amount in saving
nine that's why i like to say saving
nine is not just about the supreme court
it's not just about court packing it
explains all of the maladies that that
flow inevitably from court packing and
flowed
from fdr's court packing threat back in
the 1930s as a result of that we've got
too much power that's been moved from
the
people to washington than within
washington too much power that has been
voluntarily relinquished by the people's
elected lawmakers and handed out to
unelected unaccountable bureaucrats
people at the cdc and the fda or the two
that you mentioned you've noticed of
late it's been getting worse and worse
as the centers for disease control
is uh
a whole lot more about the control than
the disease
and the fda rather than just looking out
for
protecting the american people from
unsafe products
is all about controlling them
controlling even the information to
which they may gain access
this is the predictable foreseeable and
i believe avoidable result of congress
outsourcing the task of legislation we
have for decades had a congress that's
in effect saying we hereby declare that
we shall have good law in area x and we
hereby delegate to
commission or department-wide the power
to make
good law in that area and then they get
to make the law and enforce it that's a
recipe for tyranny
so going on the assumption that there
will be a covid ii or another version of
something this or as your wife would say
something else that will scare us in the
future
what actual authority does the cdc have
i think that was one of the things that
really confused people that every day
someone from the cdc wilensky or one of
these people would get up there they
would say something and then people
automatically felt oh that's what they
said we have to do it but that's not
exactly how this thing works right it's
not exactly how it works but there
there's enough legislation on the books
that gives these government agencies
including the cdc
at least a colorable claim
to
the authority to dictate how much of our
economy runs
that they can
get by the initial smell test and see
not everything gets litigated it's
another point i make in saving nine not
every dispute not every question about
constitutionality
goes to the supreme court most cases
don't even get litigated
a very small percentage of those that
get litigated make their way all the way
to the supreme court and it can take
months or sometimes years to get to the
bottom of some of these problems in the
meantime a lot of these disputes have
become moot and the courts then start to
lack jurisdiction over them
that's why we need
genuine deep reform where we withdraw
the authority the delegated authority to
make new law it's one of the reasons why
i believe so strongly and the need to
pass things like the reigns act look if
i were in charge of of congress and and
i had just one uh
legislative
measure that i could pick and guarantee
passage of it would be the reigns act
their acronym is r-e-i-n-s stands for
regulations from the executive in need
of scrutiny to make a long story short
it says that we're not going to allow
unelected unaccountable bureaucrats to
make our laws anymore that will be done
only by congress and when an executive
branch agency uses delegate authority
to create what is in effect a new law
that will not be self-executing after
the passage of the reins act it will
require an affirmative vote by congress
to pass it into law you see people can
fire their elected lawmakers
periodically you can't fire a government
bureaucrat that's why we need the reigns
act
yeah that's also sort of related to
something else you said before about how
our system is different than the british
system and yet in some ways we kind of
yearn for
more control it's a it's a weird paradox
that i think humans have i mean you hear
it all the time during presidential
elections what i'm gonna do the first
day in office and it's like well wait a
minute you can't do that much you're not
supposed to be able to do that much but
then they do everything by executive
action i mean i assume that's another
one that you feel like has really just
we've let it out of the bag and now it's
out of control right yes it's not just
that we've let it out of the bag
congress has now blessed it congress has
ordained this as a legitimate law making
exercise you know i keep two stacks of
documents in my office
in the senate well one stack is is short
it's a few inches tall it's usually a
few hundred sometimes a few thousand
pages long it's the
the laws passed by congress during the
previous year the other stack uh
currently
13 feet tall
it's often approaching if not exceeding
100 000 pages and it's last year's
federal register that's the cumulative
annual index of federal regulations as
they're proposed measured by height
weight
volume word count economic impact you
name it uh the
executive branch bureaucracies create
more law every year than the people's
elected lawmakers but my copy of the
constitution in article one section one
and article one section seven make
really clear you're not supposed to be
able to make a federal law without
congress
so how do we clear out some of the how
do we clear out some of that brush how
do we get rid of that bureaucratic state
or the deep state or whatever or maybe
not even get rid of it because some
version of something for stability has
to exist but how it seems like it's just
getting bigger right we talked about
draining the swamp maybe there was some
degree of it under trump but it
certainly seems like it's back and
bigger than ever right now i mean is
there do you have any levers at this
point does anyone that cares about this
stuff have any leverage to do anything
well they do only insofar as the
american people demand it and once they
demand it it will become inevitable that
it will happen that's why i think the
best single thing we could do
i i think the agenda that republicans
ought to be running on is passage of the
reigns act because that would force a
rebalancing of this balance of power
between the executive and legislative
branches too much of the power has been
given over to the executive branch
that's why we become vulnerable to all
this stuff i mean let's take for example
one of the worst abuses i have ever seen
one of the worst abuses of executive
power that's ever existed in the history
of our republic and that was
president biden's vaccine mandates
perhaps the most egregious among them
was the one that affected the most
people a hundred million people or so uh
the the so-called osha vaccine mandate
where they arbitrarily determined that
any employer with more than 99 workers
had to require vaccination of all their
employees and that any that didn't would
be senator are you telling me that's not
are you telling me that's not science 95
and then to 99 i i'd have to look at the
science here are you telling me there
was something not scientific there was
nothing scientific about it the virus
isn't that smart the virus doesn't have
the ability to differentiate between
workplaces with more than 99 workers and
those without
and the biden administration wasn't
smart enough to realize it's not within
their constitutional power to do that
but
they laid claim based on this
statute that created osha you know the
the executive branch bureaucracy in
charge of occupational
safety and osha promulgated using this
broad statute giving osha the power to
make workplaces safer
this emergency temporary order saying we
find this is necessary therefore make it
so
that's exactly the kind of thing that
does violence to our constitutional
system of government and separates the
people from their own form of government
things like that have to be repealed and
the best way to start that bull that
ball rolling
is to enact the reins act
which again would make it so that any
new substantive change
to federal law would have to be
affirmatively enacted into law by
congress are you ever amazed that nobody
gets fired from any of these
organizations i mean two years after
kovid as far as i know no one really at
the cdc got fired nobody at the uh
fda got fired you know nobody involved
at the governmental level who were
pushing mandates that either were
illegal you know potentially illegal or
at the very least immoral the series of
other things you know they forced
doctors out of work and then you know
first they were essential then they were
out of work
all of the nonsense that they did but i
don't know that anyone got fired i don't
know of any other business that could
operate this way right but why would
they get fired i mean
this is a feature not a bug this is
exactly what progressives want
progressives want to empower and
encourage that kind of thinking so of
course they didn't get fired
look
they won't get fired they won't lose
power until the people demand it and
congress acting on the demands of the
people uh relieves them of duty
when uh when judge uh oh gosh i'm
thinking uh mizell i almost forgot her
name for a second and it should everyone
should know her name the 35 year old
trump appointed federal judge in tampa
uh when she reversed the airline mask
mandate uh i had just started my book
tour i was going on like two days later
so i was going to be on a lot of planes
i was as thrilled as anybody and what
was amazing to me was that the next day
virtually i would say 90 percent of
people if not more ripped their masks
off you know a week before
fauci had just said oh we're reviewing
it again but we're going to extend it he
had just extended the airline mask
mandate thing um but meanwhile there's
been no outbreak of covet you know no
new sudden surge or anything like that
and all of the people we ripped it off
and everyone was smiling again and
talking on planes and at airports
restaurants are packed again
this is the type of thing that i think
makes people crazy it's like where where
was this one brave woman two years ago
where where did you talk to any judges
and say hey somebody could do something
about this you know i know you can't
exert influence over them but did you
talk to anybody over a scotch somewhere
in dc and say hey you could flip this
thing
well i i i talked
at great length to the media to my
colleagues to executive branch personnel
over the last two years about the fact
that it was wrong about the fact that it
was at best a stretch of federal law and
acting on a federal law that should
never have existed to begin with but
that's the thing about our judicial
system they can't just go out and act
it's one of the
things that i explain in chapter one of
saving nine the courts aren't just a
roving commission to smack down things
they don't like they've got to wait
until an actual ripe controversy is
brought before them a dispute over the
meaning of the law and it can take a
significant amount of time to find the
right plaintiff for that plaintiff to
come forward and present a case and for
the appropriate motions to be made and
judge mizell happened to be the first
one to act on one of those and i applaud
her for it it was a correct ruling
the book is saving nine senator mike lee
as i said at the beginning you're on the
short list of sane people over there so
i i wish you luck
thank you my pleasure
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell